This season on "The Drew Barrymore Show,"
one working girl takes on the world.
You know, I have a head for business
and a bod for single breasted suits.
(upbeat show tune music)
With her signature passion
and appetite for life-
Um, this sandwich, it's so good.
It is so good.
It's the best sandwich I have ever had.
I think I'll have one of those.
As a matter of fact, you can make it a double.
(upbeat music)
Whether you're a Miranda
looking for her Steve,
or just a slice of pizza.
(woman squeals)
Cheers, I love you.
I love you.
(flowing upbeat music)
This season
will leave you sleepless with excitement,
thanks to a little help from the Drew Crew.
It's you.
It's me.
Starring interior designer Mikel Welch,
chef Pilar Valdes, co-anchor Ross Matthews,
and host Drew Barrymore in "The Drew Barrymore Show,"
season two.
Welcome home.
(gentle upbeat music)